okay let's play um
blade grab this time
so the grub is actually
it does offer a kind of a cool opening
drop
which black's probably not gonna walk
into
um
i'm still offering the pawn though
thank you lebron's miracle
black playing slowly here
okay let's play e4
try and
unsolidify black's position
and now
i might as well take this knight
and queen a3
repairing this move
oh sack harder
i might play this move eventually
okay now i'm threatening made in one
block stopped it i still have this move
it didn't really accomplish anything
black's actually playing a good game
like solidly defending my threats
developing the pieces
it's a weird position
[Music]
oh
okay the goal is to
destroy the king
hey it's toggy what's up toggy
yeah if you're just joining i'm playing
very reckless and
aggressive chess but it's turning into
uh
hopefully fun
fun content
queen is watching from a distance
some idea knight f6
vision b6 could move
now box played this very well actually
this is a rated game so i have to be
careful
there's about a 1400 point rating
difference
but now it's a little bit confusing of a
position because my bishop's trapped but
there's multiple attacks against box
pieces
um
i guess that works
lights pinned
the box playing those really well man
okay i'm at least
not getting needed
this is the best 1100 i've played in a
long time
i should still be winning on time though
okay oh man
what just happened